oh my god just like your your daughter
is a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] she's you know
she should drink bleach and die
Shana Moakler gets candid about her 11
year old daughter Alabama's shocking and
frightening experience being cyber
bullied the model and actress sat down
with et and opened up about how she and
Alabama's dad blink-182 drummer Travis
Barker handled the situation what were
people saying about Alabama and and why
did it frustrate you so much well what I
don't a makeup company and I've let her
play and makeup since she was a baby and
I love Bama play and makeup and yes
she's posting the pictures but it's just
for fun she's not going you know to
school like and my makeup my makeup but
what really upset me
was that it was a 19 year old man that
kind of went after a 10 year old child
when your YouTube blogger and you have
over 5 million to 10 million fans and
you incite your fan base to go and a
threat in an attack anybody it's a
serious issue there were millions of
kids going to her page and telling her
you know what I'm gonna find you I'm
gonna hurt you in all I'm gonna die in
like all over her wearing makeup all
over her wearing makeup how did it
affect her how did she react obviously
she was upset and she was crying and
then we sat down with her we explained
to her you know how this man makes his
income and how you know we talk to them
like they're adults and I'm so thankful
that my daughter was confident enough
and had the self esteem enough to look
past what the people were doing to her
you
you